did you guys hear about the
putin's girlfriend have you guys heard
about putin's girlfriend or not you hear
anything
can you pull this up so
inside the luxury life of putin's secret
girlfriend as ukraine goes through hell
okay this is a mirror story tyler i
don't know where you found this from her
name is alina i believe right yeah i
noticed you had a picture of her on your
computer i don't know
olympic gold medal medal winning gymnast
alina caballero 38 reportedly traveled
to very private and very secure chalet
near lugano in switzerland with her
young children while russia invaded
ukraine widely believed to be the mother
of putin's two sons and a daughter or
possibly two daughters
kabeva lives in a luxurious bubble
shielded from the horrors uh her 69 year
old partner is inflicting on instant
children in february 2015 the local tv
station reported that cabeza
had given birth at a private vip
maternity clinic in sorengo on the
periphery of the city in spotless clean
streets that weave between cartier gucci
louis vuitton mega rich russian strolls
through pampered pooches anyways was
that her in the previous picture too go
back she's a gymnast yes she's very
flexible she is quote the most flexible
woman in russia well
it's true that opposites are trash she's
uh she's very flexible and and putin not
too flexible on his thoughts and
opinions is this true
for the rest of us this is a kgb torture
move but yeah
yeah you could uh put a listening device
in here
it'd be like acoustic kitty here we go
this just went to come see where i'm
going with it yeah yeah very creative
yes and you say ci is not that creative
what are you talking about you know
they're very naturally creative if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]
you